[Music]
like mother like daughter it's the best
it's just the best Kim Kardashian and
Kris Jenner stunned in sexy
black-and-white ensembles while Khloe
and daughter true are totally twinning I
love that the 37 year old reality star
and her momager turned heads while
attending an ultra private k'kaw Beauty
event for 50 lucky fans a Kim's pop-up
shop in Los Angeles
Kim was showing off her fab figure in a
plunging two-piece all-white ensemble
alongside her longtime makeup artist and
friend Mario dead Ivanovic so that's a
must for me while Kris opted for a sleek
black blazer lace tank and matching
slacks it was just a lovely combination
but Kim and Kris aren't the only
mother-daughter fashionistas in the fam
Khloe and her two month old baby girl
couldn't help being absolutely adorable
and matching ensembles on Instagram the
new mom shared these sweet snaps with
her little mama in all whites and mint
greens Khloe gushing over true in one of
the photos writing I'm so obsessed with
her I feel so lucky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]